- I was like, "Fuck, yeah,
sounds like a great idea."
So I pile into a car
filled with strangers...
and headed out
to find Santa Claus.
What could go wrong?
[police siren blaring
in the distance]
[dark electronic music]
♪
[coughs]
Ha! Yes!
[laughs]
Whoo! Whoo! Whoo!
Whoo! Whoo! Whoo! Whoo!
Yeah! Yeah!
Yeah!
[truck horn honks]
♪
- One of my best friends
in the world,
you guys are gonna absolutely
love him.
Please give it up for
Mr. Steve Rannazzisi, everybody.
[cheers and applause]
- I love pot.
I love it.
People think that I actually
have a problem with pot,
but I don't remember
their fucking names,
so it doesn't matter to me.
It doesn't affect me at all.
But I don't like
traveling with pot.
Being a comedian, you got
to travel all over the place.
I'm not good going
through the airport.
I'm paranoid enough as it is.
I'm usually high
on the way to the airport.
So the last thing I need
is to be my own drug mule,
going to TSA worrying
about getting busted, you know?
Last time I did it, Ari told me,
"Just put some joints
in an airtight thing
and put it
in your underwear."
They have these little
airtight containers.
So I put the joints
in the airtight thing,
and I put it in my underwear.
And as I'm going through TSA,
it starts to slip
down my pants leg.
And now I'm like, "Oh, boy,
if it falls out, this is it."
So I'm dead-legging it the rest
of the way through the airport.
People are like, "Can we get
the man with cerebral palsy
"a wheelchair, please?
Please."
So I don't do that anymore.
But luckily for me,
I played a character
named Kevin
on a TV show called "The League"
for a couple years.
[cheers and applause]
Yeah, thank you,
and the show's got
a huge stoner demographic,
so I'm taken care of.
Lot of heavy handshakes
on the road.
Everybody wants to smoke pot
with Kevin.
Everybody--"Oh, shit,
it's Kevin,
let's fucking smoke."
No one gives any shits
about Steve.
No, Steve is just a vessel
to take drunk and stoned Kevin
wherever he has to go.
But this pot,
it doesn't come free, you know.
You think, "Oh, you're just
gonna get free pot on the road."
No.
There's a price you pay.
Yeah.
Awkward conversations.
Dealing with people who aren't
used to smoking pot.
I smoke a fucking shit ton
of pot.
I'm used to it,
but you will get people
who just smoke so much
that they just smoke themselves
onto the spectrum.
You know? They just--
they smoke themselves special.
They'll just stare at you.
And you got to deal
with these people.
You're among strangers.
You don't want to be rude.
So you're just, like, hanging
out with them,
and they'll just stand there,
lingering, staring at you,
you know, introducing themselves
multiple times,
asking questions, answering
questions nobody else asked.
Just weird...
[groaning awkwardly]
You try not to--"Hey, man,
I think our time here is done."
They don't pick up
on any social cues.
So you have to deal
with these people.
I call these people
pot blockers, okay?
They block the fun
for everybody else.
We all want to be fun on pot,
and you're ruining it for us.
So I stay away
from the pot blockers.
And now--recently
I was in Nashville,
and after my first show--
I was doing stand-up.
After the first show,
talking to people,
hanging out after,
smoking joints with the staff,
some fans hanging out, and
it was real shit dirt weed.
So I'm not usually like this,
but I was like,
"Hey, I don't want to be
an asshole,
"but does anyone have
any better weed than this?
You know, like, I didn't come to
Nashville for this shit weed."
And they were like,
"Oh, let's go to Santa's.
I got some friends.
We can smoke some pot there."
And I was like, "Fuck, yeah,
sounds like a great idea."
So I pile into a car
filled with strangers...
and headed out
to find Santa Claus.
What could possibly
go wrong, guys?
What could go wrong?
And as I'm dri--
They're driving.
We're smoking
more of this shit weed,
and I'm starting
to get paranoid,
'cause I'm seeing
less and less civilization
and more and more
"Making a Murderer," you know?
I don't know if we passed
Steven Avery's house,
but I think I saw him.
And now I'm like, "Oh, shit."
I'm getting nervous,
'cause I'm like, "This is it."
I know what
I'm in the middle of.
I'm being kidnapped. I'm
in the middle of being kidna--
This is Kidnapping 101.
This is the first thing
you would teach--
You would be like, "Hey, buddy.
Hey, you.
"You like puppies?
"Yeah, my friend Santa's
got all the puppies.
"He's got them.
Get in the van.
He's got them in a bucket
at home--he'll give you one."
"Okay, I'll get in the van."
So I'm nervous,
and then all of a sudden,
one of the passengers we're with
goes, "Oh, we're here.
We're here. We reached it.
This is Santa's Pub."
And that's where we were going,
Santa's Pub.
Santa's Pub is the number-one
dive bar in Nashville,
and it's not really--
Have you been there before?
I mean, it's not really a bar
as much as it is
a double-wide trailer that they
tried to convert into a bar
and just shoved it
into the middle of the woods.
It looks like Santa Claus went
through a really bad divorce
in the '70s
and this is all
Mrs. Claus would give him.
Just take your shanty shack
and sit in the woods, fat man.
[laughter]
Here's a great example
of the clientele
that goes to Santa's Pub.
Beer is $1.
Water is $2.
Yes.
So anyplace--
Think about it.
Anyplace where beer is less
expensive than water
and you're not
in Flint, Michigan,
you're gonna have a good time.
[cheers and applause]
So I was like, "Fuck it.
Let's go
into this Santa's hovel."
We walk inside, and they do
karaoke every night.
Karaoke seven nights a week,
'cause it's Nashville,
and everyone can sing.
They take it seriously.
Everyone's hanging out.
They're singing.
They're getting
their songs together.
And this dirt weed
must have started kicking in,
because now I'm in the book
and I'm like, "What"--
I'm already picking out
my third song.
I've got one and two.
I've got "I'm Too Sexy"
followed by "Pink Cadillac."
In my mind, I would've taken the
house down with "Pink Cadillac."
And all of a sudden,
everyone went nuts,
because that's when
Santa showed up--
the guy that owns the place,
Santa's Pub--
and he was with his buddy,
and this Santa Claus--
he takes it
very seriously, okay?
This is not ironic Santa.
He's got the beard,
the hair, all white,
the big belly,
except he puts his own
little twist on it, okay?
He looks like Santa Claus
gave up
all that Christmas nonsense
20 years ago
and started making meth
in the woods with his friends.
He's a little rough around
the edges, this Santa Claus.
I was fixated on it.
I couldn't believe it, but
everybody else was so psyched.
They didn't care about Santa.
They cared about his friend.
They were like,
"Oh, shit, he's here."
I'm like, "Who?"
They're like, "That guy is
the greatest unknown singer
in Nashville."
I'm like, "Really?
"The guy in pajama pants, Tevas,
and a T-shirt
in the middle of the woods?"
They're like, "Oh, no, that
guy's got a voice of an angel."
I'm like, "Oh, sure.
I heard that's how Springsteen
started out, too."
Like, "Oh,
you have to hear him sing."
I'm like, "Well,
when does he go on?"
They go, "Well,
he smokes pot with Santa
"around the back
of the trailer,
and then he goes on
whenever he feels like it."
And all I heard was
"smokes pot with Santa,"
and I fucking bee-lined
for the door.
I was like, "I'm going to find
these fuckers."
30 seconds later, I am slopping
through the snow in Jordans
around the back
of his double-wide trailer.
Pitch black, I can't see
anything at all.
I'm going, "Santa?
Santa?
Is Santa here?"
Finally look over,
and I see three people.
I see Santa Claus,
the angel-voiced guy,
and a third person
who was holding court.
The guy was in the middle
of a conversation, talking,
and I walked up to them, right?
And they must have
heard me coming,
because they stopped talking
and they were,
like, they were shocked.
I guess that's
the way you would be
if a stranger came tumbling
out of the woods
and interrupted
your conversation.
So I didn't want to seem weird,
so I just was like,
"Okay, I'm just gonna
introduce myself,"
so I walk up to Santa
and I was like, "Hey, Santa.
"Hey, my name is Steve, and
I'm super excited to meet you,
and I-I really love
your place."
And he just stared at me
like, "Does this motherfucker
think I'm
the real Santa Claus?"
He probably thought, like,
"Is he gonna sit on my lap
and tell me he wants a 10-speed
for Christmas next?"
So I was like,
"Oh, okay, strike one."
So I turned to the second guy,
the angel-voiced guy,
and I'm like, "Hey, man,
my name's Steve.
"Nice to meet you.
Um, I-I heard you can--
"heard you got a great voice.
You going on tonight?"
And he's like, "Yep!"
And I was like, "Angel Voice
just left me for dead."
And I was like, "Strike two."
So I turned to the third guy,
and before I could say anything,
he goes, "Hey, I'm Bob."
And I was like, "Oh, okay, cool.
"All right, Bob.
Look at us.
"What a crew we got out here.
"We got Crystal Meth Kringle,
"Susan Boyle, and Bob.
Nice, let's smoke pot."
Except this Bob wasn't
any old Bob, all right?
This wasn't just
a run-of-the-mill Bob
you run into.
This guy, his real name was
Robert James Ritchie.
Does that ring a bell to anyone?
Yeah, you may know him by his
better-known name, Kid Rock.
Yes.
I interrupted
Kid Rock's conversation,
and he wasn't
fucking psyched.
He was staring at me like I was
Tommy Lee's dick,
just like, "What the fuck is
this guy doing here?"
Now I'm starting
to put all this together.
I was like, "I interrupted
their conversation.
"I'm asking questions.
I'm lingering.
"Holy shit,
I'm the pot blocker now.
Fuck, how do I get
out of this?"
But you know what?
I didn't want to get out of it.
I wanted to stay there,
'cause how many times
in your life
are you gonna get an opportunity
to smoke pot
with Santa Claus
and Kid fucking Rock?
I mean, if you asked me in 1994,
what do you want for Christmas?
Smoke pot with Santa
and Kid Rock.
And maybe instead
of Angel Voice,
it would've been
the fucking Joe C. guy--
the little guy that Kid Rock
used to hang out with.
He would've been
the other guy there.
So I was like,
"I'm gonna stall
"and try to wait for someone
to pull out some sticky icky,
and let's get
this party going."
So everyone is still staring at
me like I am a science project.
So I just--I go,
"Okay, what do I do next?"
So I turn to Bob and go,
"Hey, Bob,
are you gonna go on tonight?"
And he goes,
"What do you think?"
And I just went, "Okay."
And then all of a sudden,
thank goodness,
out of the front patio,
you hear someone go,
"Hey, Kevin,
we got more weed!"
And I was like,
"Oh, that's me, guys.
I got to get out of here."
And I turned and started
shame-slopping my way
back around the front.
And as I got about 10 feet away,
I heard Angel Voice go...
[whispering] "He doesn't
even know his own name."
And they started laughing, and
I was like, "Oh, this is a low.
This is a true low."
[laughter]
So I got up front
to the front patio,
and everyone was like, "Hey,
did you get to see Santa Claus?
Did you find him?"
I'm like, "Yeah.
"Yeah, I found Santa Claus.
And you could have told me
Kid Rock was
around the corner, too."
And they're like,
"Oh, bullshit, Kid Rock"--
I go, "Yeah,
Kid Rock's right there.
He's around the corner."
"Oh, fuck you, Kid Rock's"--
I go, "Listen, I understand
that I am a known liar,
"but Kid Rock--
"I understand,
trust me, I get it,
"but I promise you,
Kid Rock is 100 feet away
around the corner,"
and they all went for him,
and I used that
to slowly back my way--
and I got into a cab and I got
the fuck out of there.
And the cab driver's
driving home.
You know how you start
to replay what you--
You're like,
"Oh, what have I done?
This is not good."
And I'm like,
"How do I make up for this?
How do I make this better?"
And I go, "Okay, oh."
I text my friend
Chris Porter.
Chris Porter, comedian--
very funny comedian.
He's also great friends
with Kid Rock, and I texted him,
and I was like, "Dude,
I think I just met Kid Rock,
"and it didn't go well at all,
and just please let him know
that I am not
mentally challenged."
And I went to be feeling
much better about myself,
and I woke up
in the morning
to a text message
from Chris Porter.
It was a screen grab,
and he had cut and paste
exactly what I had sent to him
and sent it to Kid Rock,
and Kid Rock wrote back--
I shit you not--
on my sons' lives,
"Yes, he is, period."
[laughter,
cheers, and applause]
And I can't say
I disagree.
Thank you guys very much.
Thank you.